hey reject nation Greg Alba here and I'm
John we're gonna have a good day today
with the official Christopher Robin
trailer Zachary Shelton over at Twitter
sent me a tweet saying Nate it's out new
you sent me a link so thanks buddy we
also want to give a patron the day shout
out to Cameron French over at patreon
there are certain reward tiers and for
the higher ones that allows you to have
all the other reward tiers that come
before it as well
Cameron French had one of the higher
ones the patron video requests whatever
you a question was definitely put up on
YouTube we did that one I've been trying
to message him for months now
he stayed pledged to patreon so really
appreciate it buddy I'm trying to send
you a thank-you letter make it more
customized shout out do a Google hangout
with you been a couple months seems like
all you cared about was that one video
and now I'm just on this spectrum I'm
feeling bad just talk to me just one
time how many messages must I send you
to get to know you maybe this is the
thing with camera French maybe Cameron's
really hands off a fandom you know like
see one movie never watch any of the
sales you know never buying in the
merchandise
I hope in the future we do get to know
you a little bit better still say
pleasure patron that makes me happy
Wow jealousy this weekend love it but I
promised my wife and daughter I'd take
them away this weekend all hands on deck
you can't become mr. Ezard little
company out to your life is happening
now you do indeed or there
I suppose it's where it needs to be
what's a silly explanation watch thank
you oh yes I need your help
I've lost all of my friends
you know I come
[Music]
we all Christopher Robin it's you please
I've already stayed far too long
[Music]
it's nice to see you all again well I
was wrong about everything and I've got
to get back to my family
farewell Christopher Robin perhaps it's
our turn to save Christopher
[Music]
you'll bury my father stories
yes do you know what you the city
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
P G for some action that looks so dear
that looks like it like the exact heart
and spirit and there's no shortness yeah
yeah it seems totally out of the only
word I can think of this dear and that's
such a rare quality I feel like in
movies and that is a quality that is so
much we need the Pooh especially those
original stories and like some of this
dialogue and just puh lines in this
trailer are like essentially yeah yeah I
love that line I always get to where I'm
going by walking away from where I've
been who will say something like funny
or philosophic say nothing's impossible
but I do nothing every day it's like a
funny line otherwise like really wise
philosophical in weird ways this feels
like a necessary film right now yeah I
feel like it has a tonal quality and
maybe able to speak to a part of the
heart that we just don't get in movies a
lot right now could use just as a people
you know as a plot that's like kind of
reminiscent of something like hook
doesn't seem like it's crazy fantastical
I don't know we get so many movies that
are so heavy now we're really into dark
movies and whatever it's nice to get
something that feels like it's really
about just love and imagination yeah in
a way that doesn't feel too much in any
one direction doesn't feel like overly
zany or anything sincere yeah it feels
super sincere and super sweet for me I
don't get super nostalgic about a ton of
things but now we need the Pooh is one
of the earliest things I had growing up
you know I grew up with those books and
the audio books and then movies later
and for me just seeing this like it is
kind of moving I feel like at least this
trailer indicates to me that they're
handling this a really nice way to get
Jim Cummings like they have different
voice actors for all the other
stuffed animals and stuff but you know
Jim Cummings is like that yeah essential
poop air voice I'm not sure how people
are gonna respond to the the look of the
other animals in here you know I think
we said in the teaser one that they look
a little similar closer to like what the
actual dollars yeah I like that take for
this especially in real life moving yeah
yeah if they're moving into the Hundred
Acre Wood and then they're moving into
the actual you know human city I feel
like that's an appropriate way to depict
them they've found a good tone for this
I mean if the trailer is is good at
representing what the tone is cuz this
could have easily been something that
could have been like a Smurfs or eater
rabbit it could have been just some
wacky film like there's it's got some of
its wacky humor in here but it doesn't
seem overdone it seems like it's hitting
this right note authentic sincerity it
looks like a some really sweet Pleasant
time which is all you could really want
it to be it's a spirit of Winnie the
Pooh Marc Forster man I mean like it
makes sense he did a finding yes
Neverland yeah we're like every few
years he takes a break from making
really pulpy adult films to make a story
about children and a key figure in the
real world story of that children this
feels like the kind of film that I'm
gonna cry happy tears throughout and I
like the mm-hmm musics good - are you
guys excited for this
Christopher Robin movie aka the
live-action Winnie the Pooh you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is would love to have you
become a patronage act today people